[Music]
oh what a flight you know you don't fly
for two years because of the pandemic
and then you get on a plane for the
first time and you think they must have
learned something
no that's not the case
hour and a half from the tarmac
numbnuts pilot kept coming on going
you know folks we're just so sorry but
safety
first as if anybody was arguing
safety first
everybody kept saying that
what was that the dumb ass pilot kept
going you know folks it's just safety
first around here as if any other
airline is throwing caution of the wind
these aren't bits
these are my real thoughts but it does
sound like what i'm going to open with
um
and then it was really nice when
mid-flight they finally brought the
beverage card out and they go it's a
short flight people we have uh coffee
and tea
like
that'll go well with the
profuse sweating we've been doing since
the [ __ ] air conditioning wasn't
working properly what a [ __ ] show man
it's just brutal
[Music]
i'm doing shows here in boston and then
in atlantic city tomorrow my friend sal
volcano i've added to the shows
i'm gonna go out first to be nice
to make it easy on him get the crowd
ready for him and then i'm gonna let him
do some time at the end
should be good
should be good
i can't tell you how many messages i'm
getting from fans that are leading with
anybody that calls christa stefano a pig
is good in my book
someone say pig
will you talk about krista stefano
is he here
no oh that's why it smells good listen
if you if deroza's in the room you're
gonna hear about a pig
with the pig
within under five minutes that's that's
a guarantee that's a no-press guarantee
i was just telling joe joe's handsome as
it stands but when he throws on a slack
tonight he's wearing like a twill slack
i mean it's a level up i mean he just
it's a show stopper as he walks down the
hall and i'm the only one here but it
really is nice like a black on black on
black on black
you look like a rock star slash
maybe a rock executive
one of those but the boots are weathered
which is nice but then the pants are
tailored
they tail it all the way up i love that
and then the denim is like you know the
the
the black v is like you know i'm i'm i'm
dressing up but then the denim is like
but i'm also playful but then tool pants
are like but i mean business but then
the boots are like what i rock can i
tell you yeah it's all those things
i have i have a system okay okay
cash
dress
dress oh
my god
i just said that yeah but i didn't even
realize that it was your system that
just blew my balls up mix it up oh
that's so good see i'm bad i'm cash cash
cash cash
on with slacks you put slacks on with
snakes
you put dress shoes on with jeans
wow
i like that dress shoe jeans is where
you might lose me but i'm just saying i
like that's what i like i like that's
not a dress shoe no no this is the catch
the these are the dress right right but
when you said dress shoe jean that
doesn't constitute a dress shoe no no no
i'm saying though if i but sometimes you
wear jeans yeah you put on a wingtip
with it
because it contrasts against the gene
okay wayne tipper what's up top when you
got a wingtip with a gene that's tough
also dungarees please let's keep it what
it is
it's a little harder but i i i really do
enjoy a nice mix match you got wing
chips you got wingtips in the closet how
many tips you got
currently only one pair embarrassingly
but i i need some more wingtips
embarrassing i mean how many wingtips do
you need you got one it checks the box i
have a beautiful pair of tan wing tips
that i love i need a nice nice
a real nice style yeah yeah socks i mean
you're you're the shock man i love socks
i i
you know what it is i've become so bland
in my regular fash that i use my socks
sneaks i use accessories to pop you
bring cash to a new level
and i like it and i like it a lot really
i really like it i bring cash to a new
level it's nice to think anyone's
you're on point with a certain type of
pant it's very rarely denim with you
it's always a jogger or something like
that
always socks that are popping always
sneaks that are off the chain and then a
teach that's
i teach
i wear the the uh the athleisure though
because i just feel like a lazy piece of
[ __ ] really but it doesn't come off that
way
it's it's how can i be a lazy piece of
[ __ ] but dress it up a little bit that's
what i'm saying yeah it's it's it's
great but then you know what happens i
lazy piece of [ __ ] all the time then
when i do throw on a dungaree everyone's
like oh who's this guy you know i make
dungarees special you look good you look
good in a slim g
yeah yeah yeah i don't know i see that i
see the trend now going back to wide
legs i've been seeing some jenkos i've
been seeing some bells i've been seeing
some wides some baggies again i gotta be
honest i don't think i can get back into
it i was into him i don't think i could
ever back into him because i think you
heard this this uh this theory that
there's a certain age of your life that
you lock into the fashion that you are
and that's the that's the passion that
you ride out right
so i think i'm like i think i'm okay
with where i am at now that's what sent
me to the slacks
yeah was the baggy jean coming back in i
was like i can't do it no i can't do it
i can't go back to a bag i never looked
right at baggy jeans right when skinny
jeans came into play that was the first
time in my life that i looked good and
you felt hurt
the baggy jeans were like
yeah it just didn't work for me yeah no
i mean either you know we should oh we
should do you have baggaging pictures
though we could show on the pod
i'm just not sure
i'm sure i got one so we should pull up
some outfits that we
old school outfits that were captured
that were a moment in time that we're
like oh my god 100 yeah do you know what
i did do do have
my friend frank ginardi
uh a friend of mine from grade school
who i stay in touch with via social
media i haven't seen him in years but we
stay in touch
his family actually owned a chain of
grocery stores called janardis in
pennsylvania
he's a fan of taste buds he sent me he
reached out on instagram and he goes bro
i have pictures of the freddy krueger
halloween
and he sent me pictures no and i have
several pictures of us on halloween with
the freddy krueger thing and then i also
he sent me as a bonus cub scout pictures
[Laughter]
stay tuned for the next taste buds you
heard it here first i mean we got to
break the internet now you're going to
get cub scout derosa photos what kind of
cub scout do you think derosa was oh my
god
there's nothing against you nothing
against you but i guarantee you he
butted heads with a scout leader i
guarantee you it
i'm sure that i think that's where i got
a lot of my angst was being a
subordinate in cub scout
[Laughter]
oh my god i wonder if the rest of the
scouts were like
or
if you were like the champion of the
scouts that rose up against the leader
when there was any
any you know you know any friction none
of it i did what i needed to do to get
by
really i went all the way up to weeblos
i never went to eat
i always didn't understand what that
what we blow is
we blows is just not a thing to
call a group of children that have i
know watched by a comic there was a
comic in the 80s or 90s of the joke
where he goes we blows and he goes not
in my tent we know
i wouldn't
kill myself
i want to make that clear it would not
it's it's a lazy thing to cheer for but
thank you
by the way thank you that are the third
of you cheered for that
the other two-thirds are like do it
let's
let's see it
no i wouldn't kill myself i wouldn't
kill myself but
if the offer of death was on the table
i might accept
now hear me out hear me out i wouldn't i
wouldn't be proactive i wouldn't go like
buy a rope you know what i mean
but if the offer was there
let's say i was in the movies and a
shooter came in
i might walk towards the gunman that's
all i'm saying
that's all i'm saying yeah we kept a
little seeker from them that the rosa
was popping because you never know i
don't know and uh taste buds fans
represented just now i love it
so what do you typically do before going
on
what do i typically do
i
listen to the crowd
and i could see where i feel they fall
on my
meter of good and not good then i adjust
my set compared to how loud they are if
they're low and i know i'm gonna have to
work a little bit i kind of
go to more old faithfuls or actually
sometimes i'll just say effort i'm just
throwing myself into the fire and then
really get low with them
and try new [ __ ] and it's a dud but if
they're good oh god it's like you can
come out be like people
they're like
this is i'm so psyched my crowd comes
out in full effect you know and look i
already have a leg up with them they
we've had a relationship for years but i
like to like make it a little bit of a
challenge so i threw joe on the show
so he can open for me and then i could
start from low and win him back it's how
i keep in shape you know what i'm saying
here here right now you don't hear right
he's on stage
it's like running with a weighted vest
joe's on stage right now this is my
ankles they have weights on them and i'm
running in the sand
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean we were locked up you know i i i
forgot that you can i forgot that you
can die from something besides covet
[Music]
i need a drink
we're gonna have many
drinks i need cigarettes
i couldn't find anywhere to buy them in
a casino do you believe it who would
have thought
[Music]
um
we rode uh we drove today from boston no
no we flew we flew without problems
surprisingly
from boston to new york and then we got
in the car and we drove from newark to
atlantic city
and uh now we're here at the borgata
ready to do the
ready to do the show
at the event center
nothing really i went to the um
buffet for lunch
my face
you know nice buffet but they're
starting to skimp on the buffets buffet
used to be prime rib now it's brisket
no bacon bits at the salad bar
not even fake ones what would be your
buffet advice
the you got us the full salad bar
like with the with the real bacon bits
egged sliced egg ham chunks
blue cheese crumbles
sliced onion cucumber carrots mixed
olives
all your dressings i mean that's you got
to have
multiple lettuces to choose from
sliced radishes
mushrooms
they add some of that stuff not all of
it cherry tomatoes
that's a great salad bar that's where i
always start at the buffet i get the
salad bar first
then i go to like an appetizer portion
you know where i do like like i'll do
like some fried stuff and then i go in
last for the slice of prime rib
with mashed potatoes
and the brisket was good today but it
wasn't prime rib
and uh
what do you think of casinos
are you a casino guy
i should be
right
with everything uh
i mean i drink i smoke
i like women
uh you know i like you know i like the
fast life i should be a casino guy but
no i'm not i i i have terrible luck with
gambling i lose constantly
so um i you know i don't mind them i
don't mind casinos but no i'm not i
wouldn't call myself a casino guy i
don't ever really make it my goal to go
but i have fun when i'm here i have fun
when i'm at one have you ever had like a
nightmare casino
story or scenario go down
no but once um
actually this is a positive story once i
was so broke
i didn't know if i was going to be able
to pay my rent this was like 25 years
ago and my rent was uh i think my rent
was 400 for the month i had roommates
and i was so broke that i
didn't have the rent all i had was a
hundred fifty dollars to my name and my
friend called me and said come to ac
with me and i said i'm gonna go to ac
with you and i'm gonna gamble this money
and i'm gonna make my rent
and i did and it worked i wanted it
what's up sherry how you doing
how you doing
it worked i won my rent i i sat down a
three-card poker and i hit 30 to one and
40 to one right in the back-to-back so
like i made 700
immediately and what'd you spend it on
well
some things will remain unsaid but
but i did spend it on rents and
yeah i did get i did use it for rent and
then some other stuff
[Music]
well i was gonna go top this off before
you went on they're out
this is salad this is got sound this is
sal all over
let me invite you half a staten island
to the show one bottle of jameson that's
that is sound when we do the impractical
yogurt store
he tries to cut bread off the rider
because it costs an extra 1.35 cents a
job
i'm not kidding that's not a joke the
amount of times
we've planned hangs in the city yeah
and he drives
and goes bam i'm gonna need some time i
gotta look for parking look for parking
put it in a garage chintzy prick and on
top of it
take a limousine out here what are you
doing
what are you doing
frugal
i'd never drive ever again that's fine
that that's a private that's a private
decision i like driving myself as well
but to invite 30 people out of one
bottle of james said all right go have
fun
are you having a good time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
babe are you are you ready whoa we're
cooking dinner tonight babes
we got hello fresh which is america's
number one meal okay tonight we decided
to do the mozzarella and herb chicken
yeah with roasted carrots and buttery
couscous this is how it comes right get
this little
thing to follow along with you know with
them what it is you see this this is not
that was not hello fresh wow
yeah yeah so and you see how it just
slips out of your hands these
butterfingers in the kitchen because
that's not hello fresh quality hello
fresh will stick to you in a good way
those are butter hands but they're not
going to be as good as the buttery
couscous we're about to make see this is
how it's delivered it comes in the bag
all your ingredients are amazing i love
a portion
so it's just right away you have
everything they even send you fresh
produce in it look at that
and then look if you go to
hellofresh.com right now go to
hellofresh.com put in the promo code
you're going to get 16 free meals so
that's and plus three free games three
gifts hellofresh has fit and wholesome
recipes
for satisfying and nutritious meals that
you can feel good about with six recipes
per week to choose from including low
calorie and carb conscious options yeah
what else babe it's 72 percent cheaper
than going to the supermarket uh people
save over 65 bucks a month using it look
these look at these carrots 20 minute
and 30 minute meals here i mean look at
these carrots folks they're good i mean
you know and and they're edible only all
you can do is eat them look how fun it
is you just follow along first step
second step even if you don't know how
to cook yeah like myself yeah i don't
know i don't want to do anything that's
what it's going to look like when it's
over that's that's what it is like when
it's all over hello fresh has literally
saved my life they have in many
situations 50 menu market items uh so
you've got one market on it for every
state that's exactly right veggie fit
and wholesome family friendly and other
gourmet options we love we love you hear
that drilling downstairs those people
drilling to look for more hellofresh but
they won't find it because it's all we
bought at all i bought the whole stock
what's this oh mozzarella everything is
packaged from hellofresh i love it so
much it's the best
be like us cook hello fresh and live a
healthy life that's what it is look how
healthy i look look at how healthy sal
looks i look floated but you know what i
look healthy tomorrow i was eating a lot
of salt it's water weight hello fresh
now my agent asked me our agent asked us
what do you want in the ryder what do
you want in the green room we said hello
fresh because i want to get to the
theater about a half hour early and just
whip something up nice and easy what is
i want to eat it right before i go out
and when i'm out there at the conference
said no i'm treating my body right now
mean health as a matter of fact i told i
told my people i said i want to be paid
in hello fresh i don't want money
anymore just give me hello fresh food
and then i'll be good i mean my family
we're homeless but we have hello fresh
so it doesn't feel so bad for me that's
extreme i eat the hell of fresh but i
still get paid i don't want money i want
hellofresh
go to hellofresh.com
no presh 16 and use code no presh 16 for
up to 16 free meals and 3 free gifts
all right on our way to dallas see you
tonight at the texas trust center uh
about to meet sal volcano at the gate um
and it's gonna be a great trip just
gonna make one quick pit stop if you
know you know
dallas
i'm going to throw because we sit down
throwing on the kn95 under this [ __ ]
100
oh god willing this is called the roll
the dice tour
wow
roll the dice speaking of dice
this is the roll the andrew dice clay
tour
we're wearing a
the lightest of winter i'm wearing
women's underwear on my face
[Music]
hey babe
hey sal love you you're my hall pass
true 100 percent we're here uh my wife
had to get a kova test for no reason
they're not checking at the gate
so thank you very much for uh wasting 40
bucks hopefully it's worth it
hey babes what's up shout out tom brady
it's so pretty doing the most out there
i just want to give a quick shout out to
me and sal's agent for booking us at a
3500 seat venue in dallas texas at the
same exact time that the dallas cowboys
are playing to win the division title
against their rival the washington
redskins shout out our agents sorry i
watched the football team i didn't mean
to be racist
wow oh is that cake
oh it's fruit what the [ __ ] fruit meats
[Music]
do you know how to do anything on the
piano
yeah
like i don't even know where to begin
[Music]
try to deal with that
[Music]
this has been hey babe
[Music]
it's seven notes down the road
for this one this guy's [ __ ] yo mama
what does he do the violin
so
sal's over there talking to the tour
manager we actually almost cancelled
this entire run of shows because of the
omarion virus and we decided last minute
to do it and we're here now we're in
dallas texas the dallas fort worth texas
area and we're going to do a show in a
in a venue that's 3 500 uh 3 500 seater
there's 1200 uh here which hey listen
it's not that bad because you know what
it is you know what it is what we're
going to tell the crowd which is the
truth is that we did have a sellout but
half the audience died
yeah it's boxing day it's christmas
we found out today's boxing day it's
boxing day it's christmas the dallas
cowboys are playing uh
pandemic we're also fighting against um
you know communism here we are it's
december 26th we just arrived in dallas
aka grand prairie that's what it is
airport chapstick you got the airport i
never leave home without mine sibo
whoa well you make more money than me
that's probably more expensive from the
airport oh yeah true um so yeah night
one we're out of the texas trust which
we have to trust in you and the lord
jesus
christ theater yes the texas uh trust
theater um we're here and uh we got the
first show it's filling in sunday night
the day after christmas is a christmas
feel in the air christmas feel on the
air it's also a boxing day so shout out
to all my all my boxing uh day fans and
the washington uh redskins or football
team are playing the dallas cowboys in
dallas just about a mile away a mile
away they sold out 90 000 strong also we
left the hotel and everybody was
watching it so
yeah it's just one of those scheduling
snafu yes scheduling snafu but what can
you do well we're good though we got
we've got thousands of people coming
we've got thousands of people here and
we feel good we had a nice meal the
steak was a little overcooked
and i couldn't send it back send it back
and i got an iced coffee from the hotel
and they had no lid so i was just
holding a lidless cup of coffee as we
hit every speed bump coming over here i
actually turned on the air conditioner
in my room and there's a whaling sound
like an alarm is going off while the
air's on it goes
nice i said should i call down
and i didn't
wait it's a nice hotel too the four
seasons
when you roll with him you got to go
that's hey listen you know me i don't
know what it is come on look at this
looks pretty sweet and don't forget what
[ __ ] country we're from either that's
right
rocking man
[Laughter]
all right guys thank you thank you so
much
thank you texas that was awesome you're
a lot of fun upstairs have a good day
traveling driving in between cities
which is the most fun way to do it use
the blinker i'm sorry i'm sorry
look at the road not me
what are you doing i've been reading
david goggins can't hurt me it's a
really good book on discipline and like
eating the right foods
first time having these 3ds
they're good they're really good i do
don't worry about just jamming you're
jamming on the brakes
okay all right now i have [ __ ] hold
it
um they're trying to compete with bugles
i think
look out though i'm not lying man i
think i've eaten about 90 chips
let's see how many calories
there's 150 calories in 11 pieces
i've had a lot of color the queso chips
i'm sorry
today right now
they air popped these and you feel like
you're getting more for your money
because
27 pieces for 130.
now granted i've had 75 pieces
close are you in the wide-angle lens
i don't know that we're going to make it
to our destination safely if if the
driver's gone on crocs put the top down
getting four-wheel drive we're good to
go baby
what are you a wine cook
a lime cooker or a rn which one are you
there's a little people that wear crops
crack people know what's up
dude the thing is with chris johnston
he's got two earrings in his ear he's
wearing cracks in his tattoo and his
finger and the most impressive thing
about him is he's not divorced
yet
last night last night
great show
we had 33 of the room filled
great show
we we we went back
back someone takes it away from me no i
can't well if i take it away i'm just
gonna dump it into this one i'm more
than fifty percent through this bad i
feel disgusting
i went for a jog this morning and i
lifted weights but last night after the
show i i ordered from texas uh from
dallas texas i ordered uh um fettuccine
alfredo with shrimp and and i got a uh
an apple pie and a skillet and i will
just tell you that the fettuccine
alfredo was tim dillon voice not good
is it on the floor
what do you think of the sprinter van
chris so far i like the sprinter van
um
i think it's great i fell asleep in the
back row um because i ate you know 97
chips i have to pee again now um and
it's just what it is i have a very very
tiny baby bladder so i'm going to just
finish this bag of chips and then pee in
the bag and throw it out the window way
to san antonio to the majestic theater
by the river walk there
last time i stayed there i saw a
water bug
aka just a giant [ __ ] roach that they
try to get
pr and they call it a water bug i saw it
in my hotel room and now i've i've had
ptsd going to san antonio every time now
do you think the alamo was bad
that fight
you should see me fighting the water
books san antonio
i want to build a wall around san
antonio day one
we left the hotel we're hours into
driving and i realized i left my clothes
in the hotel day one
called the hotel my clothes were there
now i'm getting them shipped overnight
to tomorrow so i have no clothes right
now i have to go shopping as soon as we
get to san antonio yep i might get a
nice i might get a nice cute top
i want to get a q-top i want to get a
taco i said when i left new york
two nights ago i said i weighed in at
237 pounds i said at the end of this
trip i want to be 234. i weighed myself
this morning i'm 241.
wow the opposite direction you know the
alamo yeah i want to go to the starbucks
across the street let's do it yeah
i've heard a lot about it yeah ripley's
yes this is some real san antonio [ __ ]
let's do it dude davey crockett
got it you got it yeah
david goggins
[Laughter]
we ran into chris's mom on the road
driving the truck next to us
what's up mom
we just
made it five hour drive turned into six
and a half hours
checked into the hotel the key car
didn't work of course just got here i'm
starving they have nothing but chips and
candy which i'm gonna tell you i'm not
gonna eat but i am gonna eat and there's
also a bottle of kettle one in here that
i'm probably gonna put in my coffee
we're about to go on stage at the
majestic theater which is one of the
most beautiful theaters i've ever seen
um and right outside of it is like a
homeless asylum i mean that literally
walking dead right outside the theater
but inside gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous my only hope is that one of the
homeless people somehow manages to get
in the theater and then gets in and
chops my head off with a [ __ ] machete
then after the show we're going to go to
the river walk the last time i was in
san antonio and i went to the riverwalk
i swear to christ i stepped in a pile of
human [ __ ]
ghost spurs
[Music]
uh yeah i did check my list twice
both of the times on the naughty list
but i'll let it pass
there it is
i can't wait any longer i need something
so we're gonna do salsa and
draw five hours
tired
exhausted get to the hotel they don't
have the rooms ready get to finally get
my room ready get to the room that not
the car doesn't work the key the keypad
digital keypad doesn't work the guy
calls downstairs to one of the
assistants the manager was up there with
me he was like get me another room got
me another room so they put me in in the
room right next door which had
somebody's bag in that she he's like not
that one so
then i finally got into my room
and i'm going downstairs and i see sal
coming down because there was blood on
sal sheets
so
san antonio's off to a great start i
can't wait to get to i can't wait to get
out of this have a great set here have a
great show as good as i can
go with the homeless pimp down to the
down to one of the bars and get so drunk
and [ __ ] in the riverwalk
oh yeah this is always good
just to have whole milk
oh
who's drinking that
i can't stop eating chips
there's no chance i'm going to get to
201 pounds by june which i said on a
previous podcast so one lucky fan is
going to get to cut off my right hand
nice
[Laughter]
is that your dominant hand
no all right i could draw for both
though
sounds great out there the majestic
theater
uh there's a
i feel like it looks like it's from
disney i feel like i feel like a disney
princess
getting out there i just had lobster
gnocchi steak and a salad and a diet
coke so if you're on the front row
of this show put on a poncho because i'm
gonna [ __ ] myself
[Music]
hey
i'm just reading about the vaccine rules
for kids let me imagine that's what i do
i'm just telling you about the vaccine
rules for children in new york now like
welcome to the stage
i'm [ __ ] tired you know what the
hotel situation in san antonio sucks
[Music]
oh here's sally [ __ ]
i mean it sounds fantastic out there no
i just had lobster no key and a steak i
watched you and i'm gonna go i'm just
trying to do 35 minutes that lobster
nokia was like a cream sauce right what
do you think calories that what just the
lobster no keywords if you had to
truthfully guess well no keys are like
gnocchi's are like little [ __ ] bombs
little bombs plus the sauce plus lobster
you know lobster is your best friend on
that one do you think over a thousand
calories in that plate oh sure
you think two you think that plate of
lobster gnocchi by itself was two
thousand sixteen hundred men
yeah but it doesn't matter
what do you mean it doesn't matter
looking great listen he's gonna call you
out right now just get out there and
don't worry about the calories oh yeah
all right kill him get out there baby
make me leave here
at 3 000 act like you had a salad get
out there and act like you had
are we using the same mic
[Applause]
i forgot my mic
[Music]
i can't see anything
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
look at how tall ben is
he's like an avatar
[Applause]
i gotta follow tim dillon
[Applause]
he [ __ ] up the intro
look at home
[Applause]
is
[Music]
this is just a
warm vodka
i couldn't find
ice one of my best
[Applause]
[Applause]
i appreciate you guys coming out i know
it takes a lot you get your babysitters
all that stuff you you're in the face of
a pandemic and you came out for some
laughs and i love you and to that end i
don't want to get off the stage right
now i kind of want to bring out two of
my closest friends the funniest people i
know i'll bring about out here can i get
chris to stefano and tim dillon back out
hello hello hey
great job hello hello babies i mean how
great are you sugarland right yes
thank you babe you know this guy drove
all the way from austin to be in tonight
austin all right
now do you know this guy in the furrow
was shot in the leg three days ago
that's why he has a kid he was shot in
the lake he was shot in the leg i missed
that and he says he can't talk about it
legally but he has a cane well what up
i'm here you're safe now what the [ __ ]
happened
you it's a long story
i have i have all [ __ ] night
[Applause]
how many people want to know what went
down i would love it
it's the second time he's been shot in
his life by the way it's the second time
you've been shot in your life yeah was
it was it for the same reason
different reasons
who are you
are you john wick
is it a legal thing while you can't say
anything okay so everybody raise your
right hand
we solemnly listen i'm getting sued by i
don't give a [ __ ]
we saw him everybody raise your right
hand
we will not speak about this outside of
this arena
[Applause]
he can't do it
is the bullet still inside of you
what is this wow here it is why
did they not take the bullet out for
legal reasons
why why is the bullet still in there
oh they were trying to get it okay
here's the difference are you you and
sal here's this in you and sal you have
a bullet in your thigh and sal has a
jaden smith tattoo on his thigh that's
the difference yeah i [ __ ] do no no
no no no no no no
no no that's not true that's not true i
don't have a jaden smith tattoo i have
two jaden smith
and he has two bullets
[Applause]
hawaii's gonna pull it out
he's gonna pull it out we can't follow
this
this might be the closer this should be
because the food's here yeah
wow there you go folks
there you saw jaden a lot of people
don't know i got the second one
that he posed for
get ready to see sal's penis
there you go sal
i think what you just did was illegal in
texas yeah
thousand blackface i mean
i've been asked to take those out every
night i said no congrats you guys are
special
yes go ahead this guy yeah he looks like
a school shooter
it's okay this is not school it's okay
what what is your question
[Music]
i love gelane and i support her
she's innocent everybody who's british
should get a second chance
okay the person that's dressed as santa
oh
absolutely 100
the person who i applaud you guys came
dressed as santa clauses
give them a round of applause that's
commitment we asked you to do that and
you think you're the only two people
that said 80 degrees you have swamp you
get to ask the very last question i hope
it's good it should be a christmas
miracle
where's the lowe's gift card
stupidity we're gonna give them a lowest
gift god did we tell you did we say how
much it was
25
[Applause]
how about a room key to the four seasons
in dallas
[Applause]
i don't have any cash
all right come on oh here i got a 20. i
got a 20.
got a 20. 70 bucks
get yourself something there you go
something nice and lows
appreciate it
for lows for lows everybody here we go
yeah thank you guys so much thank you
guys appreciate it let's do it buds
i have no one else to give it to
give it to me god's honest then god's
honest
because there's a percentage it's a it's
a pie chart
what percentage of you
wouldn't
be that devastating
yeah i'll i'll answer your story just
being honest we're on the patreon he
goes sooner than later like what do you
stand you stand to profit well i think i
think rogan has the best take on this he
said they don't want whatever yeah i
said to joe and ben and his wife want me
daddy because they weren't you dead in
10 years right so that's probably true
yeah let the stock keep rising
i'm not ready to sell it but yeah you're
not going to make it to 50. not
effective if you ever take a french fry
out of your hand
no no he puts down all right
he puts a cigarette in it
he wants chad but they've become
houston's disgusting it's a horrible
city
texas is about having pride in a lot of
things that suck right it's like you
know it's like you know i love brooklyn
i get brooklyn but there's a lot of
overcompensating because it's not
manhattan right right right so there's a
lot of people that are like yo brooklyn
yeah brooklyn yeah get it love it but so
you feel that there's they're sponsored
in texas that are great
but there's a lot of [ __ ] here right
truly san antonio was again we had a
great time in san antonio it was it was
um it was it was truly it was it was
disgusting yeah it was like it's a lot
of homeless people that are four or five
hundred pounds it [ __ ] with your head
yeah that that's exactly i [ __ ] with
your sense of reality truly because it's
like the
fattest homeless people i've ever seen
yeah like their biggest problem is not
the homelessness no it's no it's like
did you eat your house yeah well people
just throw
[Laughter]
i'm homeless and i have some money to
get cholesterol well houston's also a
very bad city we we chris johnson is
opening up all the shows doing a great
job with us this week he pulled up a
fact uh before that houston's the
fattest city but also simultaneously one
of the most in shape cities in the
country so houston's what does that even
mean we couldn't figure it out on the
internet you're either a football player
or you're just like a fat piece of [ __ ]
they're just counting people that have
died as in shape yeah yeah 100 i would
say the covenant rate spiked yeah but
there's a lot of texas pride like
they're like don't change i want it
exactly how it is
right whataburger
sweet tea
my son in prison for pills he found
christ like
hey man god love god love people
whataburger's pretty good though we
don't have them in new york decent yes
you don't love it i don't love it okay
it's fine i want to get one there's a
there's a dearth of culture here
well yeah but their culture is different
than our culture like their culture is
like
shooting uh
hunting no their culture is here it's
like any other culture outside of them
it seems to be
here's what texas does that i think wish
america did more of texas melds people
into texas yeah which i think america
actually needs to do texas does not want
to be part of the united states they're
trying to defect every year
they do a great job of making people
into texans i think america needs to do
a better job of that
saying hey we're all americans now we're
not divided by nine different
uh things right we're americans you're
not a
gay trans we're indigenous we're texas
so there's something nice about that now
what about perry's steakhouse they
[ __ ] up the pork chops well they
[ __ ] it all up in paris i mean you
know right now we're dealing with every
restaurant half the staff is dead
the other half doesn't want to come in
uh supposedly you know there's real
problems good night good luck
now we got to get up in 20 minutes and
fly to saint louis
[Music]
what's up everybody tour is going very
well yes we are now in saint louis as
some of you may call it st louis yeah
yeah we were in houston last night uh
tim dillon dropped in as a surprise
guest yes we ordered a pork chop for him
from his favorite restaurant and we got
pork balls yeah pork balls yeah did a
podcast yep from the green room and this
morning we got a notification at 3 a.m
that our flight this morning was
canceled to st louis and do you think we
gave up we did not we got a bus we got a
bus and we are here in st louis for our
show tonight at the factory which is
almost sold out
yeah what do they make at the factory i
don't know what they make of the factory
i know what we're gonna be making
tonight at the factory minimum wage
ha-has
and minimum wage cut that point out yeah
yeah we just decided to sit in the same
seats yeah we're just no big deal we
just
why would we spread out no big deal at
all it means a lot to us to stay we like
to keep body contact
i ate a piece of steak three days ago
that's still in my stomach yeah well you
ate a salmon last night that came out on
the on the ride today yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah my farts were not
swimming up river
listen the flight got cancelled uh but
we still found a way to get to st louis
yeah we could have been in the hotel
room sleeping but instead what do we do
we came to the arch that's right baby
that's not how we do no and you don't
waste a minute on the road you had a
great joke about the arch why don't you
give it to him
it's built in two hours by one guy
and you know who that guy was
thomas jefferson this is why this was
built to commemorate thomas jefferson's
uh louisiana purchase but thomas
jefferson in recent years has been known
they said he had slaves or whatever and
he's been canceled and they're pushing
the statues down why don't you and i do
the right thing right now and push down
the arch
yeah and
yeah you should push it down this was
for him
got to come down tonight there's no
other way what do we do on a facebook
group we'll get a flash mob down here
we'll take it down what do i mean you
could do it babe you got look at the
cabs on you and i worked out this
morning yeah i have the kids i do have
the kids we'll do it well chris johnson
maybe can help if you just want to run
flush at it look if you wanted that
fight i run at that side
see if it could just fall back we'll
knock it right down then we'll go do the
show we'll go get some pizza
who's going up in that thing do you
think actually we should look google
this is there someone who tried to scale
the arch got it with the suction cups
got to be i bet you someone
base jumped from trump how about this i
wonder if anybody ever did this you
think anyone ever tight rope walk
it put a tight rope across it that would
be terrifying all things i want to know
how tall is it what do you estimate okay
i'm going to take a guess right now i
think that that arch from top to bottom
is one thousand
five hundred feet wow you think it's
that high
you don't think it's even one thousand
five hund
i don't think it's that high how do you
know how high the arches chris this is
chris over here
he's still not going through a divorce
even though he's dressed
in 1992 a thrill seeker did climb with
suction cups to the top and base jump
off wow a twofer a two friend and and
how uh how tall is it you out there
and then how tall are you chris the
viewers would like to know
he's gonna be 511 in your bra what movie
is that from
a liar liar
630. 630 feet
yeah so okay so that okay so baseball
fields not even so 630 feet but that
puts into perspective the freedom tower
is
1776 feet tall i sit on this pip i think
this is as tall as the freedom tower i
am legally [ __ ] you i cannot believe
that you said that and i can't believe
you said that when you knew how tall the
freedom tower was yeah i know because
freedom tower is three times higher than
that well if we wanted an elevator to go
up in the freedom tower we could take an
elevator up to here i don't think you
can go in there
no you can't there's no windows what's
what's it like in there it's like a
dungeon this window's right up there but
how does the elevator go
like slanted you got to put on a seat
belt you tell me you get off right about
there and then you start to walk up like
it's a willy wonka
give you a bunch of suction cups you
finish the rest finish the rest dude
that'd be insane
oh my god why don't we suction cup to
the top
base jump off of our free basin cocaine
and we'll do a triple whammy it's pretty
[ __ ] cool but i gotta tell you
you know i get it i get it yeah you get
here and you get it right away listen no
disrespect on st louis at all but it
does kind of feel like you guys look
around that you looked around your city
and said we really don't have anything
that anybody wants to see so let's build
an arch right by the water and you know
what credit to you because it worked
yeah we're here right now here yeah and
you've got to throw on suction cups and
go up and free basically looking for a
thrill if you're seeking a thrill
because if you come without the suction
cups and the rope there's no real stuff
that's what it is now we're going to go
now we're going to go have lunch st
louis is also famous for their barbecue
so i just hope the restaurant has wet
wipes
yeah
few and bad today the salmon the salmon
from houston really messed with me don't
get the salmon from houston texas
the staff on the southwest flight was
not liking chris no they did not like i
was farting so much that the person next
to me was like they thought it was the
plane engine but it was my [ __ ]
my asshole's as wide open as the arch
right now
630 foot [ __ ] this is a national
monument look at all the people
i'm gonna see it
no respect
no respect
one visitor now and they just scratch
that aim on the [ __ ] bottom of it
you know they built this in two hours
google it
one guy two hours
[Music]
what
you're allowed to bring folding knives
into the office
what can be brought holding knives
with a blade less than four inches yeah
so let me check mine yeah
so all the blades we have on us off all
good yeah because we got we got three
inch blades
okay
but i can't bring my bicycle i can't
bring my bicycle but i bring my blade
yeah interesting yeah well you know what
we're trying to keep everybody safe you
can't bring your blade you can bring
your
you can bring your blade you can't bring
your roller blades
got it can't bring your mace
you can't bring a dagger
i mean and you wonder why people don't
want to come to st louis can't bring
nunchucks throwing stars or cat eyes i
can't believe it says you cannot bring
nunchucks and throwing stars
that has to be just the guy that made
that sign has a sense of humor
yeah how many times are they getting
people walking in with [ __ ] nunchucks
where they were like put it on the sign
and throwing stars
you can't bring roller shoes
here's how you measure the knife
oh my god
we think it's so amusing that it says
nunchucks and throwing stuff have you
had that
who walks around with that
you guys get a lot of ninjas visiting oh
that's right that's right
they're so stealthy i hardly notice them
though
amazing look that's sick dan [ __ ] i
love st louis hey hey ready to do this
[ __ ] insane where are we at stainless
we're gonna do this [ __ ] in st louis
baby nelly we got the ark that's about
all there is in st louis but this is a
badass venue so we're gonna rock this
[ __ ]
sal chris we love you so much we've been
fan since day one shout out tom brady
shout out to tom brady hey i'd be remiss
if we didn't mention patrick bombs
[Music]
listen they have an unbelievable coffee
machine right now we're gonna go check
it out the guys who work here are
sitting and enjoying their meal and we
just ruined it
not after the chips i just ate
i'm gonna get the zen you want to set up
like where we're at
all right so right now we're at the
factory
in st louis
we thought that um before that st louis
was just
the arch that's all we thought but then
our driver showed us there's about a
million things to do in st louis so i've
made a decision to move
myself and my family to st louis we're
leaving new york we're going to st louis
i'm buying a house i'm buying a house in
st louis
it's it's for eighteen thousand dollars
in a scratch-off
game machine
i always try and
leave my mark and leave the high school
have you been successful throughout time
yeah i i have the high score in uh in a
venue in nashville on this pac-man
that's pretty much it
how do you think the tour's going so far
it's going really fun it's it's been fun
christmas was like it feels like we
haven't been home in six months
and even though it's only the fourth
night it does feel like that in a good
way
[Laughter]
there's a 100
i'm going to say over 100 there's 110
chance
that sal volcano has this exact piece of
furniture in his house by next week
the video game coffee table
this is right up south alley this should
be called the sally table
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right so we're gonna take something
from the back yeah let's do something
from the upper deck and pimp we'll do
that one thing how about this guy
walking up see see him walking up yes
he's making an effort i can see his
belly button it's disgusting go ahead
yes sir
say again
what's the next step you should watch
the [ __ ] next step because you're
gonna go over that [ __ ] balcony
yeah
the next step for you sir is getting
vaccinated because i know you're not um
you had your question what's the next
step you just turned into [ __ ]
barbara walters
what do you mean what's the next step
[Music]
this is now it reminds me of the
coliseum i think you and you need to
come down and battle to the [ __ ]
death down here yeah
what are you doing gotta throw down for
the hey babe tour 2021
got the arcs
gotta represent jersey in new york baby
you gonna sign saint louis
give it up
[Applause]
[Music]
okay oh we put the uh so here's here's
chris johnston the guy who's he's been
with us all week
is did graffiti he did graffiti as a kid
as a kid which we had no idea he's a
white man with with two studies he's in
a puerto rican gang he was in a puerto
rican gang and now he's 42 years old
with cubic zarconiums on the reg
doing graffiti on the wall and he wrote
hey babe tour 2021 which is fantastic
yeah if you take a look this is a brand
new place there's not that many things
on the wall we have a centerpiece here
right now yes so i say we go [ __ ] big
right now
you want to go big what do you want to
do no i'm just saying like
like
because it's it's our wall you know what
i mean
we'll go right under here maybe i'll do
um
what should we do
what should we do
uh listen because it's 20 21 i'll say
still
ain't
never
[Laughter]
chris
oh you want taking up some real estate
hey
that is like that is a couple of squiffy
hashtags
[Music]
you have the penmanship of a newborn
i had the delta variant should i just
write
the delta very hilarious
good
oh yeah
what happened
will people use the hashtag off the
cement wall or is that just a pop-up
different comic's going to come in the
music we have
taken up
i mean
[Music]
well you know what the place goes out of
business next year won't matter twice as
big if your place goes out of business
it should be quite slow
we did it babe we signed the wall in the
same low we did it we signed the wall i
had the delta pairing in july hashtag
oh my god chris you're gonna never ask
us back
oh
had a great show signed the wall
was so much fun come with me now
what we have to do of course i've been
on the road
for five days
so
and i ripped through um
i ripped through some holes in my
underwear with some farts so
i had to do my laundry babe there you go
there it is i'll do my laundry and i'm
putting it back in the same plastic bag
that i had my dirty laundry in so
that's what it is those salmon farts on
the plane oh dude look here look look
what i watched
homeless pimps gift
it looks great on you thank you [ __ ]
all right what do you think of the tour
so far honestly man the tour so far that
was our fourth show it's been fantastic
it's been like
dream come true type stuff the crowd
tonight in st louis was
insane um and i'm loving it man the road
is hard though i'm not gonna lie to you
going city to city after one night one
night one night that [ __ ] ain't easy man
and
i don't know if it's the water or just
to travel but i've had diarrhoea for the
last 48 hours shout out tums
what's up for tomorrow my laundry
doesn't even fit in here
what's up for tomorrow
tomorrow we got to go
tomorrow we're going on i think a 10 a.m
flight to columbus christopher columbus
ohio and then i thought we were going to
do podcasts and this whole thing but
south so we have to budget out some time
to go shopping on high street in
columbus so that's what we're doing
tomorrow we're gonna go hit up candle
stores and you know vintage t-shirt
places uh so sal can go shopping and i'm
gonna buy an outfit for new year's eve
all right
that's what it is
life
life of a comic putting your clean
laundry back in your dirty laundry bag
and then going to eat potatoes or groton
and a steak from ruth chris steakhouse
which all my life have been calling
chris ruth steakhouse because i'm pretty
sure that i have dyslexia
thanks catholic school
all right we're in st louis we're on our
way to columbus ohio right now and then
cincinnati last state we made it last
state we made it through to ohio and
then we this is all the stuff that we're
bringing on stage with us this is yeah
this is just stuff we bring on stage and
underwear and that's all it is really
these are our props
this is this yeah go buy a tupperware
shirt look out carrot top yeah we don't
have we only have size smalls left
because most of our fans are fat
we're in columbus ohio we have the show
tonight at the palace theater 7 p.m but
won't get a little shopping done so we
never come through columbus without
getting off phil thunder [ __ ]
boom magnolia we're here all the time
shout out it's a candle store
[Music]
the neck is an issue the next issue but
it's not a great story but so many times
it's like you buy a large it comes down
to your knees you buy an exhale it's a
belly shark and then the neck comes down
to here you get this quality control
yeah we talked about it actually yeah
they said they were actually changing
all the shirts exactly yeah
they're trying design but every time i
put a shirt on the next down here you
can see the top of my nipples
it's no good yeah actually this is a bed
so for your nipples very good you know
this because the material is light and
when the wind blows you can just see
yeah bad i need thick i'm looking for
thick material almost like armor that i
need to wear for my puffy tits
[Music]
we're uh
here in columbus ohio
one more after this we made it we were
worried we go on just a minute we're
gonna we're almost gonna cancel these
shows but i'm glad that it worked out
uh we had to stop way too many times for
chrissy piss breaks
and uh now he stops every 10 minutes but
it's good
[Music]
got my lady gaga t-shirt on i know i'm
gonna have a good show tonight because
gaga's on my chest and in my heart i
bought it at uh one of the uh i bought
it at my favorite store
uh in my favorite city the name of the
store is magnolia thunder [ __ ]
which is just you know well i actually
saved the receipt because it says
magnolia thunder [ __ ] and i took a
picture of it so it'd be good when
jasmine sees that and thinks i went to
some strip club in columbus
i was shopping with sal shopping with
salads and experience you need to have
shopping with sal
i don't i think sal
shops
the most of any man woman either any
human being i've ever met in my life
sal can shop them
under the table
like the way in alcohol like like like
who's the drunkest who's the biggest
alcoholic you've ever met in your life
like who's a famous alcoholic
um
my grandfather homeless yeah the way the
way the way your irish grandparents
drink at christmas is the way sal shops
on a random wednesday in columbus ohio
it's insanity and it's something it's he
does not you don't have enough camera
footage to follow him around when he
gets in a groove when he gets in a
groove it's um
it's it's just something it's astounding
and it's a beautiful thing and i'm happy
to have witnessed it and i think it's
something everybody should witness at
least once in their life to just know
just know that you can look in the
mirror safely and say i am not a
shopaholic but salvagano is
any comments back to that 100 true
i mean it's retail therapy babe
i was five days in five cities i didn't
do any shopping oh i put a bunch of
records a bunch of t-shirts a button
down i got a new pair of sneakers i mean
what are you gonna do i save room in a
bag just because i know i'm coming home
without with a haul
you know what i mean and i and i and i
make it and i don't just shop will know
either i look for the deals what do you
look for in the store what i look for is
the variety i like variety i like a
one-stop shop someone will sell me a
record a shirt
sneakers all that stuff i like that a
lot this is the first time i wanted to
say this is the first time
i've been with sal for more than
24 hours where he hasn't bought one
candle he hasn't bought one candle yet
which is
in the last store but listen but it
weighs too much for the luggage we got
one more day on the road we got
cincinnati tomorrow let's see if he buys
a candle
love a candle
so what were you thinking of this yeah
is there any chance yeah that we could
get the sign language expert up onto the
stage
oh yeah we have to
is that possible just to have her come
up here and we ask her different we ask
her different questions and different
senses and see if she can sign them
would that be possible ma'am would you
be able to come up here please thank you
okay okay we'll bring her up is that
okay can you come up are you okay coming
up yes please are you sure
oh there's two of them let's get them
both up here oh my god let's get them
both up here we'll put them on either
sides of a wall and see who's that's
great news now you guys have heard of
double penetration but have you heard of
double sign language experts i don't
think so
there it is
now
what what are your names
sign them
okay christy
and what's your name beth
what is your actual name i got it i got
it it's kevin and jeremy kevin and
jeremy that's what it is
sign language the columbia sign language
experts that's what it is they do a show
on broadway it was closed down because
of covet
what are we going for that's terrific i
mean great i really want to see do you
think would you guys do the same exact
thing is it that accurate i'm asking you
i i don't
but i don't but you
how do i
how do you know when to go and
i feel like i dropped [ __ ] ass
can i just ask the crowd can i just ask
the crowd is there anyone who's actually
deaf in the crowd
oh
oh
okay so they can stop signing then
no of course we have we have uh people
with this we have a deaf person okay yes
yes sorry i didn't see you over there i
didn't see you over there i apologize i
deserve to dive cover just like this guy
i apologize i apologize for that
oh are you dedicated to chris and you're
dedicated to me oh wait so which ones
which ones wow who's with who
which one do i get and which one does
talking this one's mine and that one's
yours wow look at that very cute all
right maybe we have a conversation we
have a conversation this is my sign
language expert
this is my sign language expert no you
did it differently you did it
differently
how's everything today
okay
um what are you doing
there's a sign for man you guys should
test how fast they can go
oh yeah
good admit
[Applause]
wow
okay ready for this dare i drop
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
wow
wow
dropping hits
holy [ __ ]
magna [ __ ] loud over here
okay my neck my back lick my [ __ ] and
my crack
[Applause]
nailed it
we did it early oh you did it already
okay how [ __ ] about this how funny is
that that we both go to my neck my back
my [ __ ] my crack okay all right here
about this i got another one gotta eat
the booty like groceries
yeah that's the first time i ever saw a
and hesitation in one of their faces she
was like
she's committed to the craft though
oh my god what it is it's like a
superpower that you guys have it's
really you guys could talk [ __ ] about us
to each other right now we have no idea
go ahead say some [ __ ] to her about me
say something negative to her about me
no but for real you signed something
negative who the [ __ ] on first
[Applause]
tell them that i'm
you i want you for real just
sign language something to her that is
terrible like make fun of me
what did she say what did she say what
did she say do we know what what do you
know what she said
can you can i ask what you said
she won't you won't use her words i said
you're an italian [ __ ]
oh
honestly oh my god look for italian
[ __ ] merch soon
it's gonna be in sign language on the
[ __ ] shirt italian [ __ ] if you
know you know that's the new merch we
got italian [ __ ] if you know you know
yeah columbus we love you guys thank you
so much man thank you
thank you thank you give it up for our
sign language experts thank you so much
thank you so much
i appreciate it thank you so much i
appreciate it i don't think you guys are
amazing thank you so much thank you
columbus we love you
we'll be back
wow this is great this is a we're doing
the chris and eddie show
and salvocano is my guess my bff for
life i took an edible five millis i'm
[ __ ] smacked a million million
i mean brown sugar pie from um from uh
the pearl in columbus ohio
brown
no that's not brown sugar
they were the last of the people i knew
that used it so i have a little bit of
an affinity to it you're a guy if it
looks like [ __ ] if i didn't know who you
are if i had no idea what's going on and
you were a homeless pimp's friend and he
introduced me to you and he said what do
you think my friend does i'd say he's a
poet
you look like a poet with the glasses
with the hair you have a poetry look
right like if you were to if you would
if you would say hey
draw a haiku i would draw a sow
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right guys last stop of the tour
here we go
baby yeah we had a great great great
time it's just hours before 2022. head
back
[Applause]
and uh we made it through the whole week
babefest 2021
and uh what up we're excited we're gonna
we decided we're gonna do a bait fest
every single year so can you give me a
clip
there will be a babe fest 2022. there
will absolutely be a baitfest 2022.
rip betty white
yes
you love her love it to death all right
babe you feel good you look good yeah
look good chin up yeah thank you you
tell me if i look thank you so much
there's a couple of wet spots yeah yeah
yeah there you go okay
hey babe the taft theater fattest
president in united states history
here's the thing we're about to perform
at the taft theater in cincinnati the
cincinnati football team just got
destroyed in the national playoff game
so those fans are drunk and upset and
now i have to go up
chrissy cuba link deal with it i haven't
taken this off in six days
how about this i
i bought i bought vinnie a bracelet for
christmas she lost it already
she [ __ ] fell though it fell in the
in the hotel
yeah and then she started crying she
started fake crying please
like i wouldn't [ __ ] like she
wouldn't just take my credit card and
buy another one
she looks very beautiful tonight she
looks very very beautiful tonight
i know when they call me up because the
whitney houston music will start
i wanted to end the new year with my
girl on my chest
whitney baby that's how went to end 2021
love it [ __ ]
love it so much
2021 out the door betty white died for
this
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
listen
[Applause]
you're the best crowd on this tour i
wouldn't lie to you
what a way to close it out man thank you
guys so so much
wow i really appreciate it
i appreciate you guys i appreciate you
supporting live comedy me and chris me
and the guys everything that you do i
wouldn't be where i am without you guys
and i really do appreciate that
let's bring them back out chris
distefano
oh my
[Applause]
don't even say it for one year in two
weeks all of our merch drops and this
week has been the only time anyone has
had a sample of it it's gonna be a lot
more than this but you guys are the
first people to have access to this
double wear t-shirt
you guys got it first um
i mean homeless pimp i mean look at
homeless pimp everybody huh guys
happy new year it's what it is man your
jeans are a mix of dungaree yes acid
wash
leather suede corduroy you're wearing
yellow sneaks and have a law top
you got the eyes of the gods eyes of the
gods
almost pimp is gay guys
so
what'd you say where's tt tt's actually
watching our children right now so
well hopefully not boiling crack um
tt is great tt jerry everybody i mean
first of all i said to myself i said to
myself and cell knows this and hypnosis
we have it on video i said to myself
last year when the when the ball dropped
i said what do i envision to bring in
2021 and i said i want to watch the ball
drop in cincinnati i said that a year
ago i said if there is a [ __ ] god
he'll have me in cincinnati and then we
got we got the call to cincinnati
absolutely this lady's having a [ __ ]
great time oh my god oh my god
you look like someone from the [ __ ]
thunderdome yes you
she looks like a robot that will
eliminate you post taste
glasses on with the mask you look wild
lady i love it i love it anybody here
from kentucky
[Applause]
does anybody have another child in the
crowd did you notice that hayden yes oh
great there you go way to go
we already got through a lot of stuff
including [ __ ] [ __ ] piss
amazing
um
where uh does anybody have a good new
year's resolution what what is your new
year's resolution sir
lie
more like that stand up stand up turn
around you could tell that was his
resolution
ponytail with a massive frizz oh my god
yes go to cvs aisle 304 pick up a couple
of things test them out come back with a
new you he looks like an old loofah
[Laughter]
cbs you forge all your [ __ ] including
your vaccination card
oh
a family doctor
your demeanor your voice and your hair
does not match your outfit you wearing a
sport coat but you're like [ __ ]
everybody
you still dress better than all of us
yeah true
bro
that's cultural appropriation sir
i'm guessing your race
you're right yeah i was gonna say you're
a white jewish woman that's exactly what
you [ __ ] are so just shut up um
yes happy hanukkah anybody anybody have
plans after this show yes
really yeah like who has good players
wait look at this guy where is it
where's this guy going sir yes
give it up for this woman softball coach
oh he's literally about to say do you
have batting practice tonight he's
driving the class trip home
that is a divorce man right there
that is a man without a family he's like
loose [ __ ]
good dude all right to the casino good
for you somebody's kids aren't going to
college yes sir all right what about
anybody is there anybody like anything
wild happen to someone this year like i
mean a life-changing event or story or
something i said this kid looked like
clay and i [ __ ] nailed it by the way
oh my god
yes you look like a skinny clay
look like you look like play again with
aids
[Applause]
yes sir oh we have someone that's going
to force away
this should be interesting here we go
excuse me my seminars parked out back
yes all right let's give him a chance
yes sir
150 for poopy out your butt
uh um i'm not sure i understand what
that means
kentucky you're gonna give what you're
gonna you want 150 to pull
you want to give us 150 to put poop up
your butt no no please please stumble
closer
let's get to the bottom of this
what exactly did you mean and when did
in what order did you lose your job
family in chile
let me just tell you something this is
you in 30 years right here right behind
you to the casino to the casino
taylor hicks you sit the [ __ ] down
you had your time and it was 15 years
ago
he's just doing the macarena
so you know that is 2 000 of us here we
will all remember this he will not
remember that yes 150 for poopy in my
butt what does it even mean
[Laughter]
what does it even mean
don't even move your violence look like
a painting yes especially you poopypants
okay
you say nothing if you have to [ __ ]
yourself again [ __ ] yourself again okay
the thing is is that the joke works if
we all follow the rules and then we will
appreciate that if there's somebody in
here that's going to yell out in that
moment
everyone in here
beat the [ __ ] out of that person
unmercifully
hey everybody it's chris and sal and we
are on the road in cincinnati on new
year's eve and we are right about at
that time
[Applause]
[Applause]
here we go
six
five
four
three
two
one
happy new year
beat the [ __ ] out of here
cincinnati we're here we're ready to
bring in the new year 2020.
unbelievable we are counting down right
now right now
10
9
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
two
one
happy new year
i knew your ass be good
[Music]
all right here's multi-millionaire
comedy superstar sal volcano playing
[Music]
[Laughter]
so we just finished our last show with
the tour
it is uh
10 after 12.
midnight in cincinnati uh we're with a
great little dive bar here i was just
running the new year uh
from the countdown of pete davidson
we we made it here uh we thought that we
were going to have to um
hear the countdown in the back of a
sprinter van on the highway in
cincinnati but it got even better and
instead we heard the countdown from pete
davidson
and then vinnie flew in you're running
out go and i'm in kino
[Music]
i played this too
five bangers in a row
i only do you'll never get less than
five bangers for me
what about the picture that he just
posted
that's an old video
that was seven bangers in a row come on
seven in a row who does that me and funk
master flags
that's gonna settle in real nice
[Music]
you